Today is a little bit different and that's because we take two Sundays every year and it's called Kingdom Impact Sunday.
We take two Sundays every year to talk about God's heart for the lost and how he wants to use us to reach people all around the world.
Starting here in Springfield and Joplin in Southwest Missouri and then the US and all over the world, we get to talk about how God wants to use us to reach
And I'm telling you, there ain't nothing more exciting than that.
That God would want to use us to be a part of building his kingdom.
What a cool thought, isn't it?
That we get to be a part of what God's doing in the earth.
And so on your seat, you have this kingdom impact card.
I want you to go ahead and grab that because this kind of outlines some of the different things last year that we were able to be a part of through our giving, through supporting different areas.
You know, last year we were able to support nearly eight
hundred missionaries all around the world.
You did that, James, of a church.
You're incredible.
Praise the Lord.
You're making a difference in all our support and all the areas that we were able to plant churches and do powerful things.
We're calling this today, Kingdom Impact, because we're moving from the name Missions to Kingdom Impact.
Let me tell you why, because Jesus defined missions in Acts chapter 1, verse 8.
as making a kingdom impact first locally, then regionally, then your country, and then around the world.
He says this in Acts 1.8, you will be my witnesses in Jerusalem, in all Judea, in Samaria, and to the ends of the earth.
Our kingdom impact, our missions giving in kingdom impact starts
with Jerusalem.
That's where we live.
It starts there, and then it expands from there to our region, to our nation, and then to the world.
And I'll tell you this, like, you know, a lot of Christians, they think in terms of like, well, you know, kingdom impact and reaching people, it starts at the ends of the earth.
But Jesus says, no, it starts locally.
It starts in your Jerusalem.
It starts here at James River Church.
And here's the truth.
Jerusalem is strong, then we're gonna do more over time to reach the ends of the earth because we have a strong Jerusalem.
And I'm telling you, that's been true at James River Church for the last 35 years as we have been able, by God's grace, to make an incredible impact in this area and all around the world.
It's been breathtaking what God has done.
Yes, and I hear somebody clapping over there, let's praise the Lord again.
We're gonna be praising the Lord a lot today.
Because we have a lot to be thankful about.
It's so powerful.
Here's why Kingdom Impact Sunday is so exciting.
It's because Jesus' heart and God's heart is for lost people.
Jesus said this in Matthew.
He said, go and make disciples of all nations.
God's heart breaks for the lost.
Today is an opportunity for us to say, God
Let our hearts break for what your hearts break for, your heart breaks for.
Let us be passionate about what you're passionate about.
He's passionate about the lost and say, God, I want you to use me to make a difference through my giving all around the world.
Do you know God wants to use you?
Do you know God?
is putting things in your heart, faith in your heart, because he wants to make a difference through you.
Do you know as you listen to the voice of God, maybe God's dropped a number in your heart to say, you know what?
I want you to write this down as your mission's faith promise for the year.
That's an exciting moment, because that's saying God's saying, I want to use you to do what I'm doing.
I want to channel my supernatural supply through you to reach people all around the world.
I want to channel my supernatural supply through you to make a difference in the kingdom of God that says, you know what?
Things are going to change where there are lost people.
Things are going to change in Springfield and Joplin.
Things are going to change in the U.S.
Things are going to change all around the world because God wants to use you.
It's a powerful moment, it's an exciting moment.
And you know, missions, faith, promise, giving is cool because we're saying, God, we want to do something big through our giving that you do through us as we honor you with our finances.
If faith, promise, giving is it's over and above our tide.
The tide belongs to the Lord, the Bible says, tide means tent.
It's the first 10% of our finances belongs to the Lord for building his church.
So it's really the baseline for us as believers when we give.
And we give and then we do over and above giving through, you know, we can do increasing our tithe or offering or kingdom impact giving.
But what we're doing is we're saying, God, this is all yours.
And God, I know is I honor you with the first.
And as I say, God, my life is yours.
My time is yours.
My money is yours.
God will bless your finances and pour blessing into you so you can make an even greater impact.
And so I want you to grab that card on your seat once again.
because I want to pray for you before we continue on, because today's the day to hear God's voice.
I think if all across the campuses, I would say if we were going to take a poll and take, who wants to hear God's voice better?
I think every single person would raise their hand, right?
Who does?
Who wants to hear God's voice better?
Look at us, look at us.
We all do.
And today's a day where we can get better at hearing the voice of God because we know this.
If God's heart is for lost people, then God's gonna speak to us about what he wants each of us to do.
And the thing is, if you wanna get good at hearing God's voice, it starts with saying, God, when you speak, I'm gonna do what you say.
Maybe God's laid a number on your heart.
Maybe you were here last week and you wrote down a faith promise, but all week God's been speaking to you and saying, you know, I love that you wrote that down, but that's not what faith would give.
And God's been burning on you, speaking to your heart a number that he's like, man, I want you to write this down, but you're like, Lord, I don't know.
God's speaking to you, and the best thing you can do is just take that step of faith to respond to what he says.
And right now, I'm just gonna pray for you.
And all of us, would you hold your card all the campuses?
If you're online, you can click a link in the chat, but father, we thank you that you speak.
We thank you that you use.
people to accomplish Lord, eternal things on the earth, kingdom impact, nation changing opportunities that you've given us.
I pray that you would speak to every heart today.
The Holy Spirit, you'd move through each person and each auditorium God in every place God, that you'd speak to us, help us to have big faith, bold faith, great faith.
And Jesus' name in a faith filled church said,
Amen, amen, amen.
Well, I'm so excited about what God is wanting to use us as a church to do this year.
And so we want to start by showing you a video of all things that we've done and things that God, we believe in God is going to use us to do this year.
Watch this.
For 35 years, one of our main outreach focuses has been planting churches.
Last year, we were part of launching churches all around the world.
21 of them were right here in the United States.
We launched with 1,005 people.
502 gave their life to Jesus.
We launched with over 570 people.
We've seen over 50 different salvation.
We have been able to make a huge impact right here in our city.
James River Church, thank you so much for your generosity.
Thank you so much for your prayers, for your generosity, and just for believing in us.
We are beyond thankful.
In addition to planting churches in the US,
Your giving made a massive global impact.
In Austria, we planted churches in areas of the country that desperately needed it.
James River enabled us in the last year to plant eight new churches in the country
with their less than 1.5% Christians.
We were also able to plant a church in Spain, and what God has begun to do in that country is incredible.
Our first Sunday, we had over 50 people show up.
Sunday after Sunday, we continue to see people walking through our doors.
We have people coming in from Asia.
We have people coming in from Central Europe.
We don't have enough words to say thank you.
Last year, we stepped out to expand our global reach and launched the James River Church Candy YouTube channel.
Since then, our Hindi and Spanish channels have grown to a combined total of over 424,000 subscribers.
And because of these channels, millions of people who speak Hindi and Spanish are hearing the gospel through spirit-empowered preaching.
In 2025, we partnered with Seed Company to translate the New Testament into 10 languages that had never before had access to Scripture.
In 2025, your church helped to accelerate Bible translation in 10 languages around the world, and every single language scripture is going out.
Each and every one of them will have a hard copy of the New Testament in their language.
Your giving has brought God's Word to over 3 million people.
This year as a church, we're so excited to announce that we're going to be part of planting 37 churches and funding vital projects all around the world.
22 of those church plans will be right here in the United States, including places like Boston, Texas, Miami, Florida, Asheville, North Carolina, and Boston, Massachusetts.
In addition to planting churches in the United States, we're also going to be planting 15 churches overseas in France, Thailand, Indonesia, and Vietnam.
These new church plants are absolutely vital to the spread of the gospel as the majority of these cities have a population that is less than 1% Christian.
We will be planting churches all across France a very, very unreached place where there are
350,000 people of just one church.
In a society that has been closed for decades, right now we see a massive opportunity for the gospel.
Indonesia is the fourth largest country in the world with over 220 million Muslim huge areas of Indonesia that the 2,000 years have never had the church a price planted amongst that city to see a 3 million.
Zero percent, Chris, we're excited about this next year to see two church plants here in Indonesia.
We really believe we could be a generational way from seeing the whole nation change.
In the poverty-stricken country of Ethiopia, less than 60 percent of the people have access to clean water.
But this year, we are partnering with WorldServe to plant five new churches, each connected to a water well that will give these communities access to clean water.
Ethiopia is the second most populous country in all of Africa.
Clean water is one of the greatest needs.
70% of all the illnesses was waterborne.
Over 15,000 children die of diarrheal deaths caused by waterborne illness every year.
These were the projects that helped us to enter to the community to start to specialize in heritage areas.
The five water projects that we're going to be doing will all have a church plan with them.
Think of the transformation that will take place.
By partnering with the Ethiopian church, we're going to see tremendous things happen in the days ahead.
We also have an opportunity to purchase a building for an Egyptian church that desperately needs it.
I'm in Cairo, Egypt.
I'm standing in front of what college hurts.
People are coming to this church and their lives are being changed.
We will come every Sunday morning is around 500, around 150, which is a service rules or screens.
We will come and just stand.
They don't have a place to sit by building this land so more souls, more people come and we will know Jesus.
We are so excited to announce that for the second year in a row, we're going to be partnering with Seed Company to translate the Bible into six additional languages.
This single project will impact over 200 million people to have access to God's word in their very own language.
One of the languages is in the Middle East, and I can't even share the name with you.
They need and want the scriptures in their language.
So you will help a growing church in one of the most hostile places in the world.
In 2026, James River is positioned to impact six
for people groups, spread out across Africa, South Asia, Middle East, and West Africa, and we're seeing that 200 million people are going to have access to the gospel because you are equipping them with the Word.
Come on, let's praise the Lord right now.
Lord, we thank You for what You put in front of us.
Lord, we thank You for the opportunities You've given us, Lord.
Praise the Lord.
That's awesome.
And for how God's used us because of our
Generosity is a church because of your generosity is breathtaking.
I'm so excited about those different things that we get to be a part of 22 churches in the US, France, what we're going to be doing in France and Thailand and Ethiopia.
It's breathtaking and then through seed company for Bible translation.
Today, as you watch that, I know you can sense the presence of the Lord here.
Let's not think in terms of finances.
Let's think in terms of results.
Today is about results.
Results being people will be in heaven instead of hell because of what happens today.
When we get to eternity, when we get to heaven, there's gonna be people that say, I'm here because you were at a kingdom impact Sunday and you allowed God to speak to your heart.
I'm here because you gave.
What a powerful thought.
In fact, Jesus said this in Luke.
He said, use worldly wealth to gain friends for yourselves.
So when it is gone, you'll be welcomed into eternal dwellings.
You know what he's saying?
There's going to be people that are going to be your friends for eternity because you gave to reach them in a country.
You never meet them in this life, but there'll be some of your best
friends for eternity because you said, God, I believe you're going to use me to reach people in Ethiopia.
I believe you're going to use me to reach people in France.
I believe you're going to use me to reach people that I will never meet, but they're going to be some of my best friends for eternity.
They're going to meet me in heaven and say, you know what?
My life was changed.
My family's life was changed because you gave.
You know, you think in terms of results, and that breaks you out of this idea that, like,
Oh, man, I don't know what I could do or I don't know how I could budget this in.
If we think in terms of what we can budget, we're going to do a lot less than faith would do, right?
That's why it's called a faith promise.
It's because we're saying, God, it's not about what I can budget.
It's not about what I can see my way to.
All of us have priorities for the year that we're like, man, we need to do this or, man, we need to do that.
If we try to fit
faith promise giving into our priorities, we're going to do a lot less than what faith would do.
But when we say God, I believe you're going to put something in my heart, a number in my heart to write down.
that God, as I step out on faith, and I start putting seed in the ground, you know, Beth and I, we love to give as much as we can, as quick as we can, because we know as we put seed in the ground, God's gonna start to bless it, God's gonna start to work, and God's gonna start to move, and we can see God do something that we can never do on our own.
That's the exciting journey of faith, and it's about results, it's about people being in heaven instead of hell, because we said, God, we believe you.
And here's the truth.
Any time we take a step of faith in any area of our life, it gives us faith for other areas of our life.
Yesterday I was in the auditorium praying over the service, and I believe God put a prayer in my heart for some people here that you got things going on in your life where you need God to move.
And as I was praying, I believe the Lord just put this prayer in my heart.
Lord, give them faith to step out and make a faith promise
And Lord, I pray as they have faith in that area that it would give them faith for areas of their life where they need you to come through, where they need your help, because that's how it works.
When we step out on faith, when we believe God, God begins to move in all kinds of ways in our life that we can't imagine.
We begin to see His blessing.
Today's a faith day.
That makes it an exciting day.
Today's the result stayed.
Jesus said this, and these are some of His last words.
before he ascended into heaven to his disciples, and how many believe some of your last words are your most important words?
Look at what he says.
He says, all authority in heaven and on earth has been given to me.
Therefore go, go therefore, and make disciples of all nations, baptizing them in the name of the Father and of the Son and the Holy Spirit, teaching them to observe all I commanded you, and behold, I'm with you always
even to the end of the age.
Jesus gives us three motivations for our kingdom impact giving in these scriptures.
The first one is Jesus has all authority.
Jesus said to them, all authority in heaven and earth has been given to me.
You know what's true about our life and about the world and about heaven and about the earth?
Jesus is saying this, he's in charge.
How many thankful for that?
Jesus is in charge.
Jesus is on the throne.
Jesus is able.
Jesus has all authority.
And you know what?
The Bible says it like this in Psalms.
It says the earth is the Lord's and the fullness theorems.
You know what that means for each of us?
Our time is not our time.
Our opportunities are not our opportunities.
Our finances are not our finances.
Everything we have.
is on loan from Jesus because he has all authority.
And that should have informed our readiness to give.
It's not mine anyway.
So if God puts a number on my heart and I'm betting my heart to say, you know what?
I want you to give this.
You know what we say?
It's yours anyway, God.
I know you have all the authority.
God, it belongs to you.
And instantly that makes it easier.
to give because you recognize it's all gods.
And you know what the cool thought is when Jesus has all authority is he has authority to say, hey, this is what I'm calling you to step out on faith to do, but he also has authority to bless you.
He also has authority to bless your finances as you give.
In fact, Jesus said this in Luke, look at this, give and it will be given to you.
Good measure, press down, shaken together, running over, poured into your lap,
For the measure you use, it'll be measured back to you.
You know who's talking?
Jesus.
Do you know Jesus has all authority?
Do you know what that means?
Jesus is saying, when you give, I'm going to bless you, but I'm not just gonna bless you with what you gave.
I'm gonna pour it into your life.
I'm gonna press it down.
I'm gonna shake it together.
I'm gonna run it over.
I'm gonna pour it into your lap.
I'm going to bless you.
And you know why I can say that?
I have all authority.
I own everything because God wants to use you.
It's not God using you financially and saying, you know what, I want to use you to fund projects in Springfield and Joplin and around the world.
It doesn't start when you go, okay, God, when I'm here, you're going to start to use me financially.
God, when I make it to this place in life, when I'm married or when I have kids or when I'm a grandparent or whenever, that's not how it works.
God wants to use you today.
God says, you know what?
I have the authority.
I'm over your life.
But as you trust me with that, whatever you put under God's authority, he blesses.
What a cool thought, right?
Okay, God, you're calling me to step out of faith.
So God's putting a number in your heart.
He's responsible for making it happen and he's okay with that.
What a good thought.
And if you put it under his story, okay, God, you put this number in my heart.
I'm gonna put seed in the ground.
God, I'm gonna watch you make it happen.
And then he has authority to bless your life.
He has all authority.
Secondly, Jesus' heart is for all people.
Look at it.
Go in, therefore, and make disciples of all nations.
God's heart is for lost people everywhere.
God's heart breaks for the lost.
He cares about lost people in Springfield.
He cares about lost people in Joplin.
He cares about lost people in Missouri.
He cares about lost people in the U.S.
He cares about lost people in Ethiopia and Thailand and France because God's heart is for the lost.
The Son of Man came to seek and save those who are lost.
That's why this moment is so
incredibly important.
Because Jesus' heart is for all people.
It reminds me of what we talked about earlier, Acts 1-8.
When Jesus is framing our thoughts, like kingdom impact giving is really in three areas.
He says, you'll be my witnesses in Jerusalem and in Judea and Samaria and to the ends of the earth.
He's saying this really starts in
in Jerusalem.
It's in three areas.
Jerusalem, where's that?
That's Springfield and Joplin.
That's James of a church.
That's us building what God is doing, where he's planted us, where he's called us.
And then Judea and Samaria, that's our region.
That's like Southwest Missouri is Judea.
And then Samaria is like the US.
And that's why we're planting 22 churches across the US because we feel called to reach our Samaria.
And then to the ends of the earth.
And historically, as a church, we've been
So, God has really blessed us.
We've been very good at reaching our ends of the earth in Samaria, but we feel equally called to reach our Jerusalem.
That's why David was talking last week about things that we're doing through Saturday's serve and the things that we want to do through outreaches in our local area because we believe God has called us to reach this area.
We believe the work is not done, right?
There's more people to be reached.
God wants to change the churches.
There's more churches to be planted.
There's more outreaches to happen in the U.S. and it's gonna be powerful.
And God wants us to reach the nations.
And that's why I'm so excited to talk to you today about what God wants us to do.
We're gonna be planting 15 churches internationally around the world, 15 new churches that we're gonna be planting as a church.
We're gonna be planting churches in France.
We're going to be planting churches in Thailand.
We're going to be planting churches in Indonesia.
We're going to be planting churches in Ethiopia.
Come on, can we praise the Lord for that?
I love that.
Let me talk to you just briefly about France because France is one of the most secular nations in the world.
In fact, since 2022,
Violent crime against Christians has dramatically increased.
It's on a rate that is nearly 50% up since 2022 with 900 incidents that are on track to happen.
Only 8% of people attend church in France.
8%.
And God's calling us to say, you know what?
We're going to reach a nation.
We're gonna plant four churches in France.
We're gonna be planting in one in Paris.
How awesome is that?
Yeah, let's praise the Lord for that.
Corsica, play bond, Rin.
Paris, the church we're planting is gonna be called House of Miracles, putting a stake in the ground for Jesus in Paris.
How awesome.
Corsica, there's one church in Corsica, only one church for every 350,000 people.
In Ren, it's 0.2% Christian.
It's a university city.
And the church we're planting there, they believe they're going to be able to plant a new church every three years out of the church we're planting in Ren.
God is going to use us to change the nation of France in Jesus' name.
Praise the Lord.
We're going to be planting churches in Thailand.
And Thailand is 94% Buddhist.
You're going to hear that a similar percentage in the places we're going because we believe God has called us to transform dark places.
Sometimes we can
Get the sense that everything's being done that needs to be done.
It's not.
There are nations that need to be changed for Jesus.
And God is calling us as a church to be a part of it.
And Thailand is going to be changed.
We're going to be planting four churches in Thailand.
I'll show you.
One of those is in Bangkok.
We're putting a church in the heart of Thailand in the capital city to say, Thailand is for Jesus.
94%, no more.
Christianity is moving forward.
The heart of God is going to be birthed in Thailand through what we're doing.
It's gonna be powerful, I love that.
We're gonna be planting churches in Indonesia.
And these dots actually on this Indonesian map are just placeholder dots, not because we don't know where the churches are gonna be planted, but because we can't announce them publicly because the church is so persecuted in Indonesia.
It's the largest Muslim country with 240 million Muslims.
And we're gonna be planting two churches, believing God is gonna change the nation of Indonesia in a powerful way.
Places, cities that have no gospel witness are gonna have a gospel witness because of what James River Church has been called to do because people stepped out in faith in a powerful way in Indonesia.
God is gonna change that country.
In Ethiopia,
We're gonna be planting five churches and drilling water wells right next to them.
I love that.
Do you know why that's so powerful?
Waterborne illness is absolutely ravaging places in Africa.
70,000 kids die of waterborne illness every single year in the continent of Africa.
70,000 kids die.
But when we say, God, we may not be able to put wells everywhere in Africa right now, but we're gonna do what you've called us to do.
We're gonna do what we can by faith.
Jesus said, if you give a cup of cold water to one of the least of these in my name, it's as though you've done it for me.
And you know what?
Thousands and thousands of kids are gonna have healthy,
clean water because of what we're going to do in Ethiopia, and it's going to open up doors for the gospel in a powerful way.
One of the ways we know this is so effective is we had the opportunity as the church to do a similar project in Kenya.
I actually had the opportunity to go to a village when we dedicated a water well.
To see the excitement
But to also hear the stories of how it opens up doors for the gospel, how Muslim clerics will come and they'll be a part of the dedication and it's an opportunity, they're being reached through what we're doing.
Towns where there's not an openness to the gospel, we're able to build a church because we did it with water.
And so I don't want to just tell you about it, I want to show you.
So check out the screens right now.
The challenge with Kenya and most of the East African countries, it's all desert.
Very, very dry areas and the communities in those areas definitely have to walk long distances in such a water.
We had projects funded by James River, they were wells and also places of worship.
They have been able to share the possible of the Lord Jesus Christ.
What James River Church did is very, very transformative.
We have about 15,000 people that are receiving water or receiving the gospel.
We have very, very clean water now.
To sincerely thank James River for giving resources that have gone into building this water project.
It's a seed that has been planted in the lives of our people and a seed that will germinate, produce and grow to have a huge harvest.
Awesome, I love that.
So exciting.
And there's more to do in Ethiopia, 60% of people in Ethiopia don't have access to clean water.
So we're going to bring change to that, put up the map of Ethiopia.
These are the places where we're going to be planting churches and drilling water wells, which is powerful and exciting.
I'll tell you this.
Another great aspect of what we're doing is the church there then maintains the well.
So the well lasts for years to come because they're able to be a part of it, maintaining it, and I'm telling you this is gonna make a difference, not just in these locations, but in the entire nation.
God is gonna use it to reach people for Jesus.
God is gonna use it to touch people who are walking, who are in darkness, and need the light of Jesus Christ.
And we're saying, God, we wanna be the hands and feet of Jesus, and we wanna share
heart of the gospel.
And so this Ethiopia project, it costs $350,000.
So maybe you would say, you know what?
I feel like God has blessed me and I want to be a part of reaching that country.
I want to adopt the whole country of Ethiopia.
Maybe you could do that.
And I'm telling you, what a powerful statement.
What a powerful act of faith that God will use you.
Or maybe you say, you know what?
We want to do a well in a church that's $70,000.
If God's putting in your heart, do it.
Step out in faith, watch what God will do.
Or maybe you want to be a part of one of the church plants that we talked about in France and Indonesia and Thailand.
Each one of those church plants costs $25,000.
So you could adopt the whole country of France for $100,000.
You could say, you know what, I believe God's touching me to change France, and I'm gonna adopt that whole nation, or maybe you say, you know what, I wanna plant a church in Indonesia, and we're gonna give you $25,000.
What God is speaking to you, that's when you step out in faith.
We tell you about the projects, because this is what we believe God is calling us to do as a church, but it says people say, you know what, I wanna be a part of what God is doing.
I wanna step out in faith.
That's when faith, combined with people taking the step of faith and giving, that's where where it's like, man, God just goes, okay, breathe on it, blesses it.
And we're able to do more than we ever thought was possible because as a church, we say, God, we're ready.
We want that.
We're, send us.
I love what we're gonna be doing through Bible translation, through the seed company.
It's gonna be powerful.
I just want you to think about this for a second.
In English, there are over 900 translations of the Bible.
Yet there are 550 languages that don't have a single part of the word of God in their language.
Not a single part.
We have over 900.
So we felt called
to say, God, we want to change that.
We're going to be translating the Bible for over 200 million people.
Put up the map where we're going to be doing that.
Here's how this works.
When we do Bible translation, we have to give you sections so we can't tell you specifically where these are.
Much like Indonesia, we're not able to tell you because of the persecution over Bible translation.
Literally, they'll go in and stop it.
But we're going to be translating the Bible.
Some of these places, we're transcending Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John.
Some of the places were able to translate nine books of the New Testament.
Some places were able to translate six books of the New Testament.
But we're saying, God, we're bringing your word to the nations.
Because how many of you know people are changed by the word of God?
People are transformed by the word of God.
As we bring His word to them, lives are going to change.
It's going to spread like wildfire.
And we get to be
a part of it.
The entire Bible translation project costs $250,000.
I believe God's touching people's heart right now to say, I want to do that.
I want to bring Bible translation to the nations.
And you know, when we bring the Bible translation to the nations, we're speeding the return of Christ.
Jesus said the gospel where we preach the whole world and then the end will come.
We're speeding Jesus' return when we bring the word of God to the nations and that's a powerful, powerful thought.
Jesus' heart is for the lost.
And we're called to have a heart for what his heart is for.
We're called to go.
Go and make disciples Jesus said.
But maybe you're thinking, well, how can I go?
How can I go, Brandon?
I live here.
Some people listening, you're called to go by actually going out on the mission field.
God's putting your heart.
Maybe he's calling you today.
But for most of us, we're called to go by sending.
Paul said it like this.
He said, how can they believe in him if they've never heard about him?
And how can they hear about him unless somebody tells them?
And how can anyone go and tell them without being sent?
For some people, they go physically.
For most of us, we go by sending, by being a missionary of supply, saying, God, I'm gonna be a missionary.
I'm gonna go by sending.
I'm gonna fill out a card, and God, I'm gonna fill this out, and I'm gonna be a missionary of supply.
I'm gonna be sending people to translate the word of God.
You and I aren't in Ethiopia.
We're not in the Pacific, translating the Bible.
But we can be there and go there as a missionary of supply.
What a powerful thought.
You could say, God, I want to be a missionary of supply.
You write a number by faith.
You start giving and you watch what God would use you to do to change a nation.
We go by sending.
And here's the exciting thing.
As we go, Jesus' power will go with us.
He says, and behold, I am with you always, even to the end,
of the age.
There's something we can be absolutely certain of.
Life can have questions.
It's like, well, I want to do this this year.
I don't know how that's going to turn out.
But here's the thing we can be absolutely certain of.
When we say God, we're going to take a step of faith.
God, we're going to step out.
And we're going to be a part of what you're doing.
We can be absolutely certain his power will go with you.
How will this happen, God?
Are you putting a number in my heart that I'm not sure how I could do it?
God says, well, I know you can't do it, but I know this.
As you step out on faith, you can be certain I will be with you.
My power is going to go with you.
You're going to see me do things through you that you never imagined were possible because my power will go with you as you step out in faith.
As you're a missionary supply, Beth and I, we've seen that.
in our lives.
Honestly, started with my parents.
I remember having conversations with my dad about moments like this where they were making a faith promise.
And him saying, you know, I was gonna do this, but after I prayed about it, I really felt like we needed to go bigger.
And then he would talk to us about the blessing they'd seen in their lives because they stepped out in faith.
And I mention that because Beth and I, we listen.
We ask the Lord, the Lord speak to us.
We put seed in the ground.
We say, God use us because we believe we've seen it.
Now we're seeing it in our own lives.
And we have our own stories to tell our kids now
of how God came through, of how God used us, and we see them stepping out in faith, saying, oh, God, would you use me?
That's the power of what's happening today.
A faith step bursts other faith steps, not just in our own lives, but in the lives of people around us, in our kids' lives.
As we say, God, we want to live a life of faith.
It impacts the people around us and it's powerful.
Here's the truth.
Proverbs says it like this, if people can't see what God is doing, they stumble all over themselves, but when they attend to what he's revealed, they're blessed.
When you say, God, I want to, I sent your presence on this.
I want to be a part of what you're doing.
God will bless you.
He'll bless as you step out in faith.
As you say, God, I want to be a missionary supply.
God, I don't know all the answers, how to work, but I know you're gonna go before me.
And you know, it's powerful whenever we can say, God, you know, I gave $70,000 and there's a water well in a church, but it's also equally powerful when we say, God, I just feel you're calling me to give to kingdom impact.
And God, honestly, I just wanna reach people everywhere.
I don't really care specifically where it goes.
I just wanna be somebody that is used by you to reach people around the world.
It's powerful and you say, God, I'm gonna give undesignated.
You know, what you're doing when you do that is you're like, because God brings opportunities to church all the time, and there might be an opportunity that we don't even know about, and God calls you to give $100,000 undesignated.
Or maybe you could give a million dollars undesignated.
I'm telling you, God, you might do that, and there might be a project that says God put that in your heart for a project we don't even know about yet.
It'd be powerful.
We have opportunities to come to the church all the time,
Just in the last year, these are things we didn't plan for that.
They came to us.
They said, hey, will you help?
And we were able to give to $5,000 to pregnancy care center, $5,000 in medication for an urgent medical trip to the Philippines, $2,000 for Bibles, $25,000 for Christ in action.
Opportunities where people came to us and said, hey, would you want to be a part of this?
You know, providing Bibles or doing this, and we were able to say yes because people stepped out and said, you know what?
I'm going to give undesignated because I don't want to see God's kingdom advance to the earth.
I believe God's going to use me in Jesus name.
Come on.
Let's bless the Lord.
You know, that opportunity in Cairo is just like that.
We sent a team to Cairo.
They went there.
We were doing a world-class camp for orphans in Egypt.
Pastor Clint.
was there on the ground.
They did it just like a James River camp.
He sent this testimony.
The difference between night one at the camp and the last night was most significant change I've ever seen.
Night one felt heavy like we had 90 students that could care less about the service.
By the last day, the worship felt like heaven, dancing, shouting, singing.
The students even began chanting one more song in Arabic after we taught them.
The leaders of the orphanage
And the missionary team said they'd never seen the kids respond like this.
So he just kept saying something is different about this camp.
And the best part of the camp, 17 students accepted Christ in Egypt at the camp.
How awesome.
So while we're there, the team attends this church in Cairo.
People are lined up outside the door.
They find out
From the pastor, this church is making a massive different state, actually recently reached a Muslim chic who was at a mosque and they said, the people of the church, the leadership were like, that's a very big deal.
This church is making huge difference.
We're talking to them and they said, we just got this opportunity to buy a building, we're wanting to buy it.
And we were able to tell them, you know what, we believe the people of James River Church are generous faith-filled people.
And so we want to help you this year buy a building, the building $63,000, and we're gonna be a part of buying a building in Cairo to say, you know what, that church is gonna be able to grow, it's gonna be able to expand, it's gonna be powerful.
But that's exactly the type of opportunity that God brings our way.
That's exactly why today is so critical.
To act exactly why we would say, you know what?
Think big.
Give big.
Watch what God will do because there's so much to be done for the kingdom.
So right now, I want you to grab your faith promise card.
And I'll just ask, don't fill it out quite yet.
But I just want you to hold it and just allow the Lord to speak to you.
Here's the thing, as you step out in faith, as you attend to what God reveals, you're blessed.
That's like this scripture.
Beth and I have seen this happen in our lives.
Beth and I, when we give, we give undesignated because we just say, God, we wanna be a part of the big picture of what you're doing.
But we wanna do something significant.
My dad always says this and it's become, it's evident in their lives, my mom and dad's life and it's become part of how we think about giving.
We don't want what we've done in the past to be the measure that we use in the future.
We always wanna say, God, we wanna do more.
Maybe you've had an opportunity like this in the past and you've kinda just let it be the standard
God's calling you to move beyond that.
Maybe last week you wrote down a number and you're feeling like the Lord is saying, you know what?
I want you to do something big, something beyond what you think is possible.
I'm telling you, if you step out in faith, you'll watch God do something you can never imagine.
So maybe you did write that number, and when we do fill these out, you'll just write up the top new card.
If you wrote a number last week, write new card at the top.
When you do that and say, you know, I believe God is using us to do more, and then put seed in the ground, because what seed in the ground?
That's starting by giving.
You don't just fill out a faith promise.
You just say, God, I want to give as much as I can as quick as I can.
Beth and I like to put significant seed in the ground.
We want to do something that says, God, we're serious about this.
And God, we are serious about believing that you will bless us as we step out in our giving.
We know you will.
And we can't wait because it's
God can only bless what you give him.
So when we do the faith promise, we do that because we say, God, if this is going to happen, it's going to have to be from you.
And so when we put that seat in the ground, it allows him to bless and multiply in a powerful way.
And maybe you're just thinking like, right now, I just don't know if I have the supply.
That's the point.
You don't.
God does.
You may not know your way how it's going to happen, but God does.
Trust him.
Watch what he'll do.
He'll do incredible things.
And before we fill this out, I want to read you this testimony.
So the Lee, Lee wrote this, my wife and I felt strongly that we should make a faith promise for $60,000.
It was close to 40% of our annual income and was definitely a faith promise.
As Pastor John says, give as much as you can as quickly as you can.
And we were able to come up with $6,000 trusting God.
to provide the rest.
Throughout the year, we watched as unexpected events begin to unfold as a business owner.
Our business had grown substantially.
We were hoping to sell it.
Through a divine encounter, another company, another company expressed strong interest in purchasing our business.
We ended up selling it for over 30,000 more than expected.
The sale of our company was approximately five times my annual income.
This allowed us to write a check for the full amount of the faith promise as well as tithe and we're so grateful.
There's something inside of a person that is released when we let go of our finances and trust God with the results.
Since that time, our finances have multiplied greatly, unexpectedly, and we're overjoyed.
We are praising God for His faithfulness, His abundance, and grace.
Come on, let's praise the Lord with them.
Praise the Lord.
So I want you to grab your card and you can begin to fill it out.
I want to say a couple of things you can fill out every week I intend to give, every month or this year.
Beth and I,
We write down what we believe God is gonna do through us through the year.
Once again, if you're like, this is a new faith promise, I filled out one last week, but I feel God's calling me to do more, you just write new card at the top.
Let me say this, don't sign it like with a doctor's signature or something we can't read, okay?
We won't count it.
Or if you sign it like Tony Stark or something like that, we won't count those because we're counting.
These are things that we're saying, this is what helping us know what we can commit to doing as a church.
the people of James River are believing to do.
So make sure you write your name.
Once these are filled out, once they're counted, we shred them.
So we're not gonna come back to you with it, but we count them once again to know what we can commit to.
And this is you saying before the Lord that I believe God's gonna use me to do this.
So go ahead and fill it out.
And then once you fill it out, you can tear it off.
It's perforated.
And then I'm gonna pray for everybody and the hosts you can get into place, but I wanna pray that the Lord pours his blessing into your finances.
As you say, God, I'm gonna put seed in the ground.
God, I'm gonna make a faith promise.
I'm gonna believe you do something online.
You can fill it out.
We have a link in the chat.
Every campus, we're doing this all together.
We want everybody to be a part of this moment.
Let's hold up our faith promises.
I'll pray a prayer of blessing over every person.
Father, I thank You, Lord, that You supernaturally supply, and I pray, Lord, for every single person making a faith promise today.
Lord, I pray,
that you would pour the abundance of heaven into their finances.
That you pour the abundance of heaven into their homes, God.
That you pour the abundance of heaven into their businesses.
God, we're saying right now, we're about the kingdom.
We're about seeing your work advance in the earth, God, and so I pray you're blessing on your church as we do this on your people in the name of Jesus, amen, amen, amen.